si vous possédez un compte en banque si
vous utilisez internet si vous recevez
sur votre messagerie mail des
sollicitations de votre banquier pour
vous identifier
méfiance plusieurs banques font
actuellement l'objet d'une attaque par
phishing sur le site internet autour
dire que les pirates accède au fichier
des banques que si vous répondez à leurs
courriers ou lors donné toutes les
instructions nécessaires pour vider
votre compte en banque
explication séverine lebrun et à la
location alerte sécurité sur les sites
de deux grandes banques françaises leurs
clients sont victimes d'une arnaque sur
internet
ça s'appelle le phishing démonstration
vous recevez un mail qui semblent
provenir de votre banque
sous prétexte de changer de système de
sécurité on vous incite à donner toutes
vos coordonnées bancaires
en fait tout est faux des escrocs ont
copié le site de votre banque et
récupérer ses données pour vider vos
comptes
alors si vous recevez ce message bonjour
c'est crédit mutuel qui vous salue nous
sommes contents de vous présenter notre
nouveau système de sécurité ou le même
type de mail semblant venir du crédit
lyonnais
surtout n'y répondez pas vous avez
affaire à des escrocs copier un site web
il n'y a rien de plus facile envoyez un
mail à un grand nombre d'avs reste mêle
aussi c'est très très facile donc
réaliser le phishing c'est très facile
et le gain en fait peut être important
avec un investissement vraiment mineure
alors méfiance surtout qu'il vous sera
difficile si vous vous êtes laissé
piéger de récupérer les sommes
détournées
le plus souvent la banque vous à vous
opposer que vous avez donné un nouveau
code confidentiel et donc vous engager
votre responsabilité que vous êtes
montrés négligents
néanmoins elle engage quand même sa
responsabilité pour avoir mis ce service
à disposition sans vous informer du
risque que vous couriez en l'utilisant
pour l'instant seuls quelques plaintes
ont été déposées en france mais
attention ce type d'arnaqué et de plus
en plus fréquents elles ont doublé en un
peu plus d'un an avec la haute